okay so better called soul is a prequel
that manages to do the impossible not
only does it match breaking bad in terms
of quality but it also in many ways
surpasses it season 6 episode 8 was a
testament to this and the entry point
and shoot feels like one of the tensest
hours of television that i've ever
watched
but why is that well you better call
paul as we're going to be breaking it
all down in this video we really
appreciate the thumbs up if you agree
and also make sure you subscribe for
videos like this every day now it's rare
that prequels ever catch you up to where
the originals were in terms of quality
and off the top of my head i don't think
i can actually think of one that's
beaten what's come before to me prequels
have always been a bit pointless because
you already know how the story is gonna
end and you're very much just watching
the setup to your joke you already know
the punchline too it's one of the
confines of the genre and whether it's
the thing star wars prometheus or
whatever a lot of the time prequels fall
short you can completely predict the
beats but what better course all does is
that it uses this to its advantage
because we know what's coming it
constantly leaves us guessing whether
this is the moment that it's gonna
happen or not for example we know that
kim isn't with jimmy come breaking bad
but we still don't know why was she
killed did she finally see sense or has
she ordered a new dust filter for her
hoover max extract pressure pro model 60
we don't know and that's exactly the
point every time she's put in danger we
will i i sit there thinking is this it
now episode 7 in the series ended on a
massive gut punch after ruining howard's
reputation throughout the season he
ended up showing up to kim and jimmy's
home here he berated them for what
they'd done and for how pathetic that
they were as people it was a real
talking down that felt like when people
enjoyed the video but don't hit the
thumbs up button and they could have
ended the episode there however instead
we got lala appear out of nowhere and he
killed him lalo has been a big shadow
hanging over the entire show and even as
far back as breaking bad he was
mentioned by saul when jesse and walt
first went to him
barlow didn't send you
oh thank god oh christ
are you kind of understand why saul is
still paranoid over him come the end of
the entry and it may have been a factor
in breaking him and came up lala said he
was coming back he's not coming no he
said he was he told me you understand me
he is not coming
back now one thing that's rarely talked
about in the show is how it subliminally
reuses images in order to set things up
down the line and there was a moment in
this that was absolutely perfect earlier
on howard had shown that if one were to
spin a can that they could defuse the
fizz in it so that it wouldn't explode
this twisting motion was later mimicked
by lalo twisting the silencer on his gun
showing how and it's all connected like
alelo shot and killed him and they
showed he wasn't messing around the gap
between that episode and this one was
agonizing and you really didn't know
what could happen to either jimmy or kim
that's why when you think kim could be
left behind with lalo at the start of
this one that you really start to freak
out however jimmy convinces lalo to let
kim do the job instead it shows just how
protective that jimmy is and how he can
switch on a dime from panicking to the
slick hustler that can always talk
himself out of a situation he's of
course doing this to save her life as he
knows how dangerous this could be and if
he doesn't manage to do it that she'll
die instead he's sacrificing himself so
that she can do the job and what job is
that well killing gus fring one of the
most memorable villains of all time this
is a guy so paranoid that he has doubles
of himself and even wears a bulletproof
vest on the off chance someone tries to
take his crown he's very much presented
as a guard at point in this entry that
lurks over everything but this episode
also paints him out in his most
vulnerable state lala lays out the job
early on in the entry and he says that
all they have to do is drive to an
address knock and then shoot the person
who answers the door until the gun is
empty they're given an idiot-proof
weapon and a time limit that shows it
won't even take that long door opens
you point
and you shoot
and you keep on pulling that trigger
until it's empty
hard part's over now you pull out the
camera same principle as the gun point
and shoot now this idea of someone
getting gunned down as they answer the
door is something that has of course
appeared before in breaking bad we had
jesse rushing to gail's house so that he
and walt could get job security and the
ladder later practice skyler about being
the one who knocks it's all brought
across in this episode and when kim goes
we get in what most circumstances would
be a pretty boring scene there's a slow
approach in her car a stop at the light
and a long focus on the police next to
her before she slowly walks up to the
door it's a long scene but you're on the
edge of your seat for the entire thing
will she reach out to the police for
help will they stop and question why she
looks so suspicious will gus answer the
door will mike recognize her before it
all goes down yeah just sitting there
like canel please just let me know now
to add to this we also have the curled
opening that shows a shoe washing up on
the beach what better call soul does
expertly is that it often gives you
breadcrumbs of what's to come and slowly
start to piece together everything so
you understand the full context of it
it's what makes the show so engaging and
throughout we have mentions of shoes
which constantly draws our memories back
to the opening even when we get the
title sequence we can catch howard's tie
in the background but i don't think
there's enough there for anyone to fully
draw conclusions there's also the
attention to detail and when we cut back
to jimmy and kim we see the candle is
still burning at the exact same length
as how we left it and the blood is
running along the floor now this episode
of this core is very much about lalo and
fring playing a deadly game of cat and
mouse with each other whilst both jimmy
and kim are used as pawns in their game
there's very much this idea they're
playing four dimensional chairs with
each side constantly trying to out with
the other this entire season has been
about the characters trying to be one
step ahead and we finally see what
happens as a result of this it's all
about the long game and we even watched
their final confrontation all getting
built towards back in episode 5. gus set
up the lab so he had a way to trigger
the lights to turn off and he even
counted the paces up to his own gun so
that he could get to it in the dark this
is something that he ends up doing when
he and lalo enter the lab and he points
and shoots killing him in the process
tony dalton dies with a smile on his
face and this perfectly sums up the
character we all knew he wouldn't make
it to breaking bad and going out like
this outsmarted by gus was the best way
to close out his ark but deep down i
think he's laughing here because he has
respect for gus due to how much he
studied him throughout the entire season
he's seen firsthand how well set up his
operation is and just things like his
underground network really show how much
he's planned everything out i also love
how almost all this entry is shot at
night it really adds to this being
something that feels like it's going on
in the dark hidden away and once the sun
rises it'll shed light on the entire
situation so they have to work fast now
that isn't the end of the episode and
there's still a situation with howard
it's really been a devastating series
for him as we heard about not only his
marriage problems but he of course also
got murdered obviously it's pretty bad
and the way things are left off he's
gonna forever be remembered as being a
drug addict that ended his own life
howard got caught up in the wrong crowd
and obviously didn't deserve any of this
there's a horrifying shot early on where
jimmy stares into his lifeless eyes and
you just see the emptiness and the life
that's been robbed from him this heavily
mirrors the death of hank and in the
aftermath of that wall 2 had to look in
the face of the person he just killed
which is too echoed in jimmy he and lalo
getting buried together cements that
will never look at the lab in breaking
bad in the same way again but judging by
twitter at least the pair are having a
nice afterlife together now there's
somewhat of sadness in seeing them both
get slumped over each other in the grave
and these massive charismatic characters
are just left as lifeless corpses never
to be heard from again overall it's just
a master class in storytelling and
tension and watching mike slowly put the
pieces together over what's going on
throughout the episode rises the stakes
throughout the entire entry lalo is
doing this all to film a video for
donaldio and watching gus say how
pathetic he is really hits home he
delivers a devastating message to him
and as we saw in breaking bad the
character spent years setting things up
in place of how he'd take him down
there's a focus on the light and the gun
and it just makes for an amazing scene
he wants to talk hector and how he's
leaving him alive until the very end gus
finally makes it to the gun and he pulls
until it keeps clicking much like what
lala wanted jimmy and kim to do in the
end he was the one who got to point and
shoot this idea is carried throughout
their face-off even to the point that
lalo points both the camera and the gun
at him at the same time now what the
show also does brilliantly is that it
just deposes these dark moments with
light ones that feel like they're ripped
from another world watching lila greeda
opening up the restaurant while scarce
is getting patched up feels like it's
got such a dark sense of humor to it
that it's difficult not to smirk whilst
it's all going on everyone is so
oblivious to gers and they'll also be
oblivious to what's really happened to
howard jimmy and kim are given a story
and though they'll likely get away with
it things can never go back to normal
howard was murdered in front of them in
their own home and it's unlikely that
they'll ever be the same although we
don't know what happened to kim i think
this could spell it out jimmy was able
to adjust and put this to the back of
his mind when he became soul whereas she
likely couldn't this episode very much
comes full circle at this point and just
in the same way that it began with a
pair being told what to do here they're
once more sat down and being instructed
what a saint think
mike has done something similar this
before and in fact his first scene in
breaking bad was him telling jesse the
cover story for jane's death we then end
with a slow burial of howard and lalo
whilst mike looks over them it's a
closing of the chapter that he clearly
regrets to another way but it's just
another part of the game overall it's an
incredible episode and something that
stands out is one of his strong points
in the season i absolutely love it and i
can't wait to see what happens towards
the end of the series now and of course
love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we're running a competition right now
and giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our perfect scene breakdown of the boys
season 3. we go over that big fight at
the end of here orgasm and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want some more appreciation for what's
going on in it without the way thanks
for sitting through the video i've been
paul i'll see you next time take care
peace